let's start today with an update on how
the pandemic is going in the united
states and around the world this is
probably the
the least good update that we've had
in a couple of months but it does
require some thought and some
explanation and there's some details to
understand so
the the top line like the bad number the
number going in the wrong direction is
cases
cases per day in the united states and
around the world
are now climbing once again and after
more than two months of declines and
significant declines for much of that
two two and a half month period
average daily cases are again ticking
up not by that much but from a low of
about
55 000 new cases a day in the united
states
now up about five percent to 58
000 cases per day remember context
these are numbers many in 2020 thought
we would never get to
we blew past them all the way up to 255
000 cases per day came back
down and now we're back up from 55
000 to 58 000. what is driving this
we're vaccinating we're vaccinating
millions per
day at this point and we'll look at
those numbers how is it
that cases are again going up couple of
different things going on
one is that in some states the more
contagious british variant known as b117
is becoming more widespread now remember
that the vaccines work really well
against b117
but among unvaccinated people it's going
to spread more
that's exactly what is happening for
example in michigan michigan is a place
where b117 is becoming
uh more widespread as the variant of of
dominance
and michigan's cases aren't just ticking
up slightly they're skyrocketing
primarily again among
unvaccinated people michigan cases are
up 250
from a recent uh low so the other aspect
of this is is more of a sort of uh
i guess you'd call it a psychological
aspect in a sense as
people learn about vaccination and they
hear that people are getting vaccinated
and they hear that cases are coming down
some people
choose to behave less safely and there's
an analogy here to something
that traffic engineers deal with when
traffic engineers
look at a stretch of highway or road for
example that is a lot of traffic and
they say we need more lanes in order to
better accommodate traffic
they will start a project to widen a
road
and of course people learn about the
fact that the road is going to be
widened and will have more capacity
and often what happens is that by the
time that the road is widened
increasing capacity more people because
they have heard hey
this road will have more capacity so
traffic will go down
more people choose to use the road and
so by the time that the road is done
you have more capacity but traffic is
moving just as slowly because more
people are choosing to use the road
similarly we are seeing spring breakers
in florida
states rolling back all guidelines etc
as cases started to come down because
vaccination
was going up and the seasonality effect
more people are behaving less
less responsibly less safely i guess we
would say and thus we are starting to
see
cases tick back up now despite cases
going up
the good news is that deaths continue to
decline
for now as we know at this point deaths
lag cases by about
three weeks we're already three weeks
out from cases leveling
deaths continue to decline from their
peak of about
nearly 3 500 a day towards the
middle to end of january now down to
about a thousand deaths a day that is a
decline of 70 percent
but the decline the rate of decline is
slowing down
and one signal that might not bode so
well
is in terms of people going into the
hospital
new hospitalizations have also continued
down
but the rate of decline is slowing down
significantly so
this is a crucial period of about i
would say two to three months is what
most of the epidemiologists say
it's a battle of vaccination versus
variants and we have very good data
about how good
the vaccines are i read yesterday a
study
which tracked california health care
workers
after being vaccinated and what the
study found was that
the fully vaccinated health care workers
meaning 14 days out from dose number 2
something like 0.05 percent
became infected this is a group that's
highly exposed
working in health care settings around
unvaccinated
sick patients very low rate of contagion
among those who are vaccinated so that's
the good news
vaccinations now averaging right around
2.5 million doses per day
that's a combination of two dose
vaccines
and single dose johnson and johnson
total 2.5 million doses per day that
number
should continue to grow it appears that
it is going to continue to grow but this
is not a good time to start going crazy
the way we've seen
spring breakers do in florida so super
zoomed out
vaccinations up deaths down that's good
medium term hospitalizations leveling
out
not declining that quickly lately cases
up
and vaccine distribution in much of the
world
not good and ultimately i mean to really
get back to normal
as a global village for lack of a better
term
other countries are going to need to do
well on vaccination there are countries
not expected to get
significant access to vaccines until
2023
maybe wouldn't even fully vaccinate
until 2024 who knows what variants we'll
be on to by then
so that this is a bigger issue now we're
starting to hear
you know more about vaccine equity and
and countries like the u.s and the uk
hoarding vaccines and different issues
as i've said before
i think it's perfectly natural that
countries would try to vaccinate
their own people first but there is no
question
that until there is more vaccine
distribution
globally we are not going to be able to
say that we have
we have dealt with the pandemic but
let's keep vaccinating
uh all you can do here in the us is when
you can get a vaccine get one
that's what you can do one of our
sponsors
is monk pack it's tough to get excited
about most granola bars they have a lot
of carbs
they don't taste that great they don't
really satisfy your cravings
but monk pack has something totally
different monk pack
keto granola bars are sweet and
delicious
with a soft and chewy texture
only 140 calories one gram of sugar
and only two to three net carbs which
make them work
perfectly for the keto or low carb
lifestyles
they come in excellent flavors like
coconut cocoa chip
honey nut blueberry almond vanilla
that's my new favorite
i love these because you can just grab
them anytime maybe it's a quick
breakfast an afternoon snack when you're
busy
forget the dry bland granola bars you've
had in the past
try out monk pack keto granola bars
if you don't love them like i do they'll
give you all of your money back
you'll get 20 off when you go to
monkpack.com and use the coupon code
pacman the link is underneath this video